without holiday and other guards
it's been giannis and middleton bringing
the ball up in the corner grayson allen
that's a three
how about the pass though
slow to get up here look at this with
your left
right
in the shooting
bucks are coming off the loss monday at
charlotte by 4.
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's where giannis i think is even
better you can't you have to form a wall
when he's going downhill three guys in
the paint he's just finding his teammate
best record in the nba the warriors 30
and 10.
into hood knocked away wiggins lost it
how do you stop this
race it now and then right there
you got to make a decision
well the bucks were looking for a little
bit of good fortune at home anyway three
by portis again he'll train it from
outside
give him 20. he's got to have that
effort
thomas has got a double-double with 30
and 10. he also has nine assists
and he has another assist that they have
just awarded so he does have a
triple-double
three good
[Applause]
and it's time to get janice out with
that triple double
[Music]